would you all meet george carter hey
baby what's that dude
we got [ __ ] scumbags jerk offs and
[ __ ]
and they all vote
he was funny he was smart he was
opinionated i wanted to be just like him
he was just so cool here's the list of
words you can't say all the time [ __ ]
piss [ __ ] on [ __ ] [ __ ] and
ted and the crowd goes crazy
[ __ ] pissed [ __ ] [ __ ] constructor
[ __ ] kids they arrested me for
profanity the supreme court restricts
the broadcast of dirty words remember
jump show right now he's the beatles of
comedy
i began this dream of standing in front
of people and having their attention
my mother was his biggest champion she
just had a way of lifting people up and
believing in them they were comrades in
arms but then what happened was super
stardom
my mom was alone all the time she's
feeling left behind and now the drugs
are there and that really did undermine
everything in our family i did as much
cocaine as there was in the immediate
three county area at that time
he had collapsed in on himself my career
began to wane i had to find my voice
in 1988 we were going to go to the show
to laugh at him because he was this
older comic and carlin came out with
like a howitzer now they're thinking
about banning toy guns and they're gonna
keep the [ __ ] real ones
he didn't want to be that george carlin
anymore you want to be a different
george carl what i really was was a
rebel
we can't educate our young people can't
get health care to our old people but we
can bomb the [ __ ] out of your country
all right
[Music]
stand-up's the hardest thing he did the
hardest thing for the longest time
[Applause]
he was challenging society to be
better life is sacred who said so god
hey if you read history you realize that
god is one of the leading causes of
death
george is still relevant he changed
comedy three or four times and he's
still talking to us things that he was
getting at were so profound to the
culture what would you do if you were
the planet trying to defend against this
pesky species
viruses
they try to divide people so that they
can run off with all the [ __ ] money
[ __ ] is the glue that binds us as a
nation it's the american dream
because you have to be asleep to believe
it
[Music]
you